a meursault le groupe rouge est un
acteur majeur des travaux publics dans
la région chantier de la rcea chantier
du tram des contrats de grande envergure
les matériels utilisés sont à la même
échelle l'engin comme celui ci consomme
plusieurs centaines de litres de
carburant par jour en phase de
production et l'impact de la
modification des taxes sur le gnr va
donc induire une augmentation des coûts
de carburant et de production de
plusieurs centaines d'euros par jour il
est à noter que ce genre de machine on
en a plusieurs dizaines sur nos régions
de production s'il avantage fiscal sur
le gasoil non routier disparaît il y
aura des conséquences financières non
négligeables
on peut effectivement aujourd'hui
estimer l'impact de cette hausse de nos
carburants à environ 700000 euros
la modification de la taxation sur les
gasoil non routier va nous impacter de
l'ordre de 50 centimes d'euro du litre
c'est de l'argent qui sera indisponible
pour qu'on puisse investir recrutés
formés
et nous financer dijon nord sur le futur
chantier d'un siège social bancaire le
ballet incessant des engins fait
comprendre combien la mesure risque
d'impacter les entreprises de travaux
publics alors que le secteur connaissait
une embellie six roues de cette réforme
fiscale
il est clair que l'on va être obligé
contraint d'augmenter nos prix ça va
coûter plus cher à la collectivité de
foot fait de la hausse des prix est
forcément donc
là les budgets publics sont quand même
en en fait diminution donc aux femmes en
travaux à terme
et ça je suis très très inquiet la loi
de finances de 2010 9 supprimant
l'avantagé fiscal du gasoil non routier
serait adoptée au plus tard le 21
décembre dans l'immédiat les
professionnels du secteur ont prévu de
rencontrer le préfet de région vendredi
prochain pour faire part de leur
mécontentement